- Home security cameras.
They can be great for
monitoring deliveries,
keeping an eye on your house.
And of course, spying on your cats.
In fact, around 14% of US
households with broadband
now use an internet connected camera,
and the US market for
home security cameras
is projected to continue
growing rapidly through 2030.
But their popularity has come at a cost.
- Amazon's ring doorbell may
not be as private as you think.
- [Newscaster] Hackers tapping
into those home cameras.
- [Hacker] I'll leave
you and your family alone
or I could do this.
(alarm blaring)
- Just this year, Amazon-owned ring
handed over surveillance
footage to law enforcement
11 times without a warrant
or customer consent.
- The company said the
request met its exception
for emergencies, which it
defines as danger of death
or serious physical injury.
And since cats have nine lives
and always land on their feet,
I figured Koneko, a
Manhattan-based cat cafe
wouldn't it be at any risk of
law enforcement stepping in.
But there's a stereotype with cats
and it's that they're burglars.
And we'd like to prove
otherwise with this video.
So, that's why it's the perfect place
to come and outline some dos
and don'ts for you to consider
when setting up and installing
some of the latest smart
surveillance cameras.
Of course, Joe Golka,
Koneko's cattery guide
was with us all day to
ensure that these rescued
and adoptable cats were
happy and comfortable.
- Right?
You're gonna hang with me?
- [Kenny] And that no real paws were used.
- [Nicole] Is my hand in it.
- [Staff] Yeah.
- [Kenny] If you want
your valuable recordings
shielded from prying eyes
you should try to enable
end-to-end encryption.
But what does that mean
and what does it do?
To keep it simple, let's
say cameras typically use
one of two encryption types.
There's standard encryption
and then there's end-to-end encryption.
Imagine two companies,
Cat Cam and Dog Cam.
Cat-Cam has end-to-end encryption
which means the only user
with the key to decrypt
your video files is you.
Well, you and anyone you
share the account with.
So, end-to-end encryption
protects your data from hackers
and prevents it from
being viewed by others
such as law enforcement or Cat Cam.
Dog Cam encrypts your video
when it's traveling from
you to company servers,
but it doesn't do it end-to-end,
which means the company
can also hold the key
to decrypt your recordings.
If you're looking for
end-to-end encryption,
Nicole recommends a camera that works
with Apple's Smart Home
platform called HomeKit.
- I like these devices
because end-to-end encryption
is on by default.
Logitech's circle view camera
or doorbell are good picks.
They work indoor or outdoor
and have face recognition
to identify different
people in your household
or frequent visitors.
- [Kenny] End-to-end
encryption isn't limited
to just HomeKit cameras.
For instance, you can now
enable it on some ring cameras.
But it's not on by default
and another important note,
it's not available for
their battery powered models
and disables some key features.
No matter which brand you choose,
be sure to use a secure password.
Don't point your camera at private spaces.
Security cameras usually
have ultra wide lenses
that capture far more
than say a normal smartphone camera would.
So it's important to consider
the expectation of privacy
when installing one.
Ask yourself.
What would you be comfortable with?
If you've got a doorbell-style
security camera,
try not to capture a shot into
your neighbor's front window.
And if there's a zone in
your camera's field of view
you'd rather not capture,
try enabling motion
detection or privacy zones.
- Cameras from these brands all feature
activity zone triggering.
Any HomeKit camera, such as
those from Eve or Logitech,
Ring, Google Nest and Arlo.
Ring devices can also
set up privacy zones,
which will black out areas
from being recorded in videos.
- [Kenny] Do consider location factors.
If you're looking to monitor
an entire space indoors
it's best to keep your
camera at a higher location.
This will give you the
widest field of view.
Then ask yourself,
"Do I need night vision
in my camera's location?"
If so, make sure your security camera
has an infrared spotlight
which will enable it
to capture video and images
in little to no light.
Also, if your camera is
being used as a baby monitor
or in a location where
silence is important,
it's worth noting many
security cameras can click
when activating their infrared light.
- If you're in a noise
sensitive environment
try disabling night vision
and buying a separate
infrared illuminator.
And always be sure to let
everyone in your household
or location know there's a camera.
- [Kenny] Don't forget
about hardware quirks.
In the world of security cameras
you have outdoor cameras
and indoor cameras.
Battery powdered cameras
can live outside for months
without having to be recharged
or having any pesky wires run to them
which makes it easy to forget
when they need to be charged.
Don't be a jerk or creep.
- [Nicole] Many brands
let you clip recordings
which can then be posted to social media.
Ring even has its own
network called Neighbors.
- This for a place like
Koneko can be great
when they wanna post clips
of their in-house influencers
for public consumption.
But security cam users
should always think twice
before posting to social media.
That's because it's easy for
nefarious internet passersby
to triangulate your location
simply by landmarks outside.
Also a case of mistaken
identity or misunderstanding
can lead to an accidental
tragedy, somebody getting fired,
all sorts of bad things.
So, before you post something
online, take a breath,
think twice and consider the outcome.
(staff member laughing softly)